bienvenidos a enlaces centroamérica este
capítulo desde uno de los puntos de
frontera de dos países del triángulo
norte porque aquí pisamos suelo
guatemalteco pero cruzando del otro lado
del río se encuentra el territorio de la
república del salvador y es que hoy
hablaremos del operativo de seguridad
llevado a cabo por el ejército de
guatemala luego de que el presidente en
allí buque le tomara la decisión de
decretar un estado de excepción en su
denominada guerra contra las pandillas
decisión que motivó a varios países
vecinos de centroamérica a blindar sus
fronteras pero también a encender las
alarmas ante un posible éxodo masivo de
pandilleros o de mareros como se les
conoce en esta región del mundo el
ejército de guatemala ha redoblado su
presencia militar a lo largo de este río
el río la paz el comandante de la
tercera brigada infantería del ejército
de este país centroamericano el coronel
juan orlando le hemos ha dicho que
aunque no se ha registrado ningún cruce
ilegal de parte de pandillas a
territorio guatemalteco la seguridad
sigue desplegada hacemos patrones aéreos
y
sobre todo acabamos de hacer un patrón
he aéreo en todo el límite político
internacional con la república del
salvador entonces no hemos visto ningún
incidente en los 203 kilómetros que
nosotros tenemos no hemos visto nada
si ustedes ven son pequeños casos
aislados en los que se han dado de
capturas de maderos pero en esta área no
se ha dado no se ha dado incidencia
verdad desde que inició el estado de
excepción en el salvador ministros de
esa nación se han reunido con sus pares
guatemaltecos para que las medidas del
presidente nadie bukele no repercutan en
la seguridad de guatemala
las fuerzas armadas de ambos países han
establecido estrategias conjuntas de
vigilancia fronterizas llamadas
patrullajes combinados de contacto en el
caso de guatemala y el salvador se
tienen identificados 59 pasos no
controlados en la frontera es decir
cruces del río donde no se pone en
riesgo la vida y por donde es posible no
ser detectado sin embargo con el
fortalecimiento de unidades militares
estos pasos no controlados ahora son
patrullados constantemente y varios de
ellos cuentan con vigilancia permanente
de soldados en terreno el resultado ha
sido
y positivo porque no hemos tenido
ninguna podría decirse invasión de gente
ilegal verdad no hemos tenido en ningún
foco de
estas agrupaciones de maras o pandillas
no hemos tenido ninguna situación y la
presencia militar en combinación con un
ministerio de gobernación y la policía
nacional ha disuadido este tipo de
acción de estas bandas delincuenciales
en guatemala
en días posteriores al decretado estado
de excepción en el salvador el ministro
de gobernación de guatemala napoleón
barrientos apuntó que ha habido amenazas
de parte de pandilleros en esta área
fronteriza
la intención de las maras sería la de
expulsar a los guatemaltecos de sus
viviendas las familias residentes en la
aldea las flores pertenecientes a la
ciudad pedro de alvarado sienten temor
ante esta posible amenaza ahorita
estamos bien pero todo este tiempo trans
en un estado sin seguridad
y nosotros en el temor pues éste
prevención a la familia por qué sabe qué
estamos cerca del salvador
pues aunque el camino ahorita en el
verano el río todo paso va de baja el
agua pues la gente se tira por donde
queda
y llegarán como de camino aunque no sea
el camino el miedo se incrementó entre
los habitantes guatemaltecos de la aldea
de las flores luego de confirmarse el
asesinato de un marero en la colindante
aldea de agua tibia un ajuste de cuentas
entre pandillas alertó a los vecinos que
la mara salvatrucha se encuentra en la
zona
que si hace como más de un mes este
asignaron muchacho a que creo que andaba
en la pesca
son personas que las personas son que no
tienen compasión de nadie más entonces
tal vez la puede pagar el que no la
deberá entonces también nosotros por
todo ese movimiento como les repito va
decidimos mejor retirarnos antes que se
vaya a pasar algún miembro de nuestra
familia cualquier cosa verdad y como lo
repito es más importante la familia que
dejaron de uno ha nacido hoy ha vivido
a 6 km de la aldea de las flores nos
encontramos en ciudad pedro de alvarado
que funge como puesto aduanero
inmigratorio entre guatemala y el
salvador donde por ahora la frontera se
mantiene tranquila
de acuerdo con las autoridades militares
la migración irregular que está cruzando
por el río en estos momentos corresponde
a familias provenientes de países como
nicaragua el salvador haití cuba
venezuela y la república democrática del
congo
mientras sigue la vigilancia para evitar
el ingreso de pandilleros a guatemala el
ejército de este país se encarga de
realizar su labor constante y regular
capturar a los migrantes que transitan
los cruces ilegales para entregarlos a
las autoridades migratorias quienes a su
vez los retornan a sus países de origen
gracias por acompañarnos en este enlace
centroamérica desde la frontera entre el
salvador y guatemala en la cámara estuvo
mi colega aurora vall y recuerde que si
quieres repetir este programa lo puede
hacer ingresando a nuestro sitio web
france24 puntocom hasta pronto
[Música]